[Music]
we're here in Melbourne Australia still
and some relevant podcast al Jackson
special guests comedy legend Franklin
that's a wrong no that's good okay cool
yeah I didn't know I was a legend that
people told me that in the states I said
why aren't I working I can't figure out
the connection you know just say yeah
Garson bridges are now look it was just
a deal from you it was just a different
like you know it's it you know what's
interesting is when I was a younger
comedian you know I I was I kidding I
was dealing with Richard and in Eddie
and in def Comedy Jam
and in my style which is low-key was it
was really kind of swamped during that
time and I had a tough time as a black
comedian because I wasn't really raucous
yeah Affairs you know which after so why
would you start
I started in 72 okay yeah I started by
that most of that time most of the black
comedians were pretty mellow you know I
came up after Dick Gregory and Cosby and
who told me to send you his regards
Salamis I decide and so the tradition of
black comics were pretty pretty pretty
much low-key and I didn't what I was I
liked Carlin Pryor and Robert Klein in
particular you know those were my three
kind of models and that counterculture
kind of rebellious comedy but very
low-key I was always kind of low-key but
then I got I kind of got lost
you know when comedy got more raucous
the black comedians got more raucous and
that became to be kind of expected then
I but I think the tide is turned because
you know Dave yeah is low-key you're
low-key Michael Cera's low-key I don't
know who he is but when I was here
people used to email me and say there's
a comedian in the States
reminds me of you and and then when I
said who is a guy to get that email a
lot from doing people myself it's this
guy named Dave Chappelle so ironically I
went back over to the states in 2005 to
do
and I ran into Dave at The Comedy Store
we was doing a benefit and I was there
and he was there so we got to chatting
the first time I did my thing and then I
Dave did his thing and I actually
listened to him first time and I went
wow I can see why they say he's similar
to me and we chatted afterwards and he
said I used to come see you all the time
Washington DC I used to sit in the front
row and he had my album don't smoke dope
fry your hair he told me and he named
all these places I had been in DC Wow
that he would see me
and I I forgotten yeah all these places
so I went okay alright cuz I didn't know
it I saw so I used to think I had no
influence over anybody's yeah comedy you
know I just thought well I'm not gonna
be not that I wanted to be influential
but I used to see when I saw that the
you know I would talk to young comedians
down at the Uptown Tommy and they were
all very high-energy right know and
they'd all come out five six of them all
high-energy and I'd say well you know
you can't really distinguish yourself if
you're all gonna be high-energy yeah you
know and why don't you try talking to
him a little bit more but that seemed to
be a lost kind of thing well I had that
I remember doing a set on the south side
of Chicago yeah I'll never forget I had
to set it was a kind of black open mic
and I did - and my first couple years
ago did all right
it was pretty badass and then I was in
the bathroom there's another comedian
and he said man your material is good
but you gotta yell at these
[ __ ] to say that because that's
that's actually true because I had a I
had some young black comedians can come
up to me cuz I did this thing
comic view for B et yeah and I judge
something some comedians and I tried to
talk to him about and a lot of them said
oh I really like your material is really
smart but the black audiences won't let
me do that I got that comment from a lot
of young black means they won't let us
do what you're doing so I had to tell
him something which was kind of
interesting because when I started of
course there were not really black clubs
to like they liked this pregnant the
folk rock clubs yeah I worked the bitter
in and there's a place in Georgetown
called the
[ __ ] that the I forget the name
of it or Hendrix get out of there - yeah
Oh Jimmy Pryor I did the Village Gate I
did a I did all the tours when I started
turning 72 of all you would play were
the folk rock clubs yeah the troubadour
the bitter end the cellar door in DC
Paul's Mall in Boston
eva's feel in Denver of the place in
Philadelphia to be you and I would
always be the opening act for a musical
act you know either a folk or a jazz act
mostly jazz you know so that was
actually really great because the
musicians really liked my my act and it
was perfect for me to read with a jazz
act because they bring an audience
that's ready for abstract stuff yeah
okay and so it was ideal then then I was
sitting the comedy boomed and then I
started headlining at the comedy clubs
but also I didn't you know I miss making
a lot more money and of course you know
but I didn't enjoy it as much as when I
worked with the music collects wretch
was really more of like I just kind of
like that that blend was the comedy boom
because I hear so much about it it was
that was the 80s yeah and so was there
was it a gradual thing where all of a
sudden exploded or was it out of nowhere
like oh [ __ ] I'm getting 10,000 a week
what was the like how did it they want
to exhale it did you feel like oh you
know The Improv was packed every night
comedy store was packed every night
stars were dropping by yeah I remember I
was hanging out Bruce Willis came was in
Michael Fox all you know it was packed I
mean literally packed you know it was a
booming and of course the clubs exploded
you know all around the country comedy
clubs everywhere which was dangerous
because that was a saturation and you
had all those shows like evening at the
improv you know so you and I did this
show a long time ago make me laugh which
was actually the best show for my
profile it because you're on five nights
straight oh wait explain the format of
the show was called make me laugh and
they'd have like three comedians
and they bring out somebody and they'd
sit there in the chair yeah and your
thing was to make them laugh like in 30
minutes or a minute or something like
that so Louise audio well there was an
audience there but there was also they
bring out this one person who sit in the
chair and his goal is to try to not
laugh yeah and so you would so you know
you have about three contestants and you
come out do your thing I could always
made mine laugh somehow you know but you
are on five nights a week right what
happened was a lot of people could see
you in that week we're doing it
tonight's show they might see you might
do one but they wouldn't see you for on
another one for three months like that
make me laugh thing I remember yeah oh
yeah I mean cuz it's very popular it was
a very popular show at that time but
what happened was the producer ended up
stealing all this money so they took all
this they took the show off there
yeah the producer stolen stole all this
money so but I remember people easy to
steal the producer not even get a check
he was able to steal from yeah he stole
I mean it was ridiculous he had him I
had him a cash cow who's gonna be around
for years I think the way it was so
properly I was knowing how he managed
stole the money stolen it tanked the
show that's that's what I heard yeah I
heard that he embezzled or he did a
bunch of stuff and next II know the show
was off the air was so syndicated show
was back on our regular Network has make
me laugh you could look it up google
them and that really I remember I got
recognized a lot more could you feel
your audience I could feel it yeah
because it was you know you had
everybody young we were all about the
mandela's Armbrust bomb response well
people doing it so you have to make the
person laugh so you're doing yeah yeah
it was no you come to it you come you
know I knew the pitch I had and you'd
walk right up to him he'd be sitting in
a chair and you start to do your bit to
them yeah you know
and I had some good stuff at that time
and they'd always kind of laugh I crack
him up you know and that was cool but
the boom back to the booming thing you
know you just comedy clubs were
everywhere you had a you had all of
these brick you know you had you had a
and he had evening at the improv then he
had the Laugh Factory had his show I
used to do that a lot too
yeah okay on TV show and that's it was
just buddies on TV making money but a
cat said you know then he said you know
there's too many comedians which was
true and there's too many clubs a guy
said that a camisa there's too many men
and that was it just saturated people
mediocrity yeah I started to hear it was
just getting into business I get them no
because that's when it kind of changed
in the 80s before then people wanted to
be a comedian to be a comedian in the
eighties people want to be a comedian to
be a sitcom star that was the change in
the attitude of the people getting into
it because my five minutes gonna be
literally that's gonna lead me to you
know cause Jerry had his show Roseanne
had her show Cosby had really hit you
know yet Tim Allen and it changed they
weren't really trying to be great
comedians anymore I tried to be when I
got into it I I saw the people that I
really admired and they were like
inspirational to me Carl and Richard and
Klein in particular I was kind of a
synthesis of those three I had a college
education Richard didn't have I liked
his kind of street oriented sensibility
because I'd gone to black high school
and I was could relate to it on that
level or not you know he was I saw him I
remember honest my 21st birthday at the
red fox Club we had Fox used to have a
club this one Richard Martinelli yeah
what an egg but she was exiled from TV
and he went changed his act from being
clean to this is when he went to
Berkeley yeah yeah and he came back a
friend of mine have called me from San
Francisco said man if you go but you
probably start with your pyre in
Berkeley if you get a chance to see him
and never you got to see him just catch
really plenty and lo and behold my
birthday came up in my and I saw he's
planning to red flags club like they're
on La Cienega and my girlfriend said
I'll take you to see him
and the interesting thing was was what
take is 75 cents and what was
interesting was I didn't know what kind
of material he was doing because I'd
only see him do enough my name is
Rumpelstiltskin stuff I didn't know he'd
really changed into what he you know
really did telling the truth and Kirsten
and all of that so what was interesting
was um my girlfriend was white she was a
young girl she was 18 I was 20 she was a
little Catholic you know you really
couldn't curse around her sweet the real
sweetheart actually from San Francisco
so we went to see him and of course
Richard started cursing and doing his
thing and I remember she gasped
initially when she started to hear to
show around but the funny thing was it
taught me a lesson was by the end of
that show she was absolutely hysterical
yeah she was and I made I realized that
the truth of something because I thought
wow I can't curse around here here's all
this language and stuff right and all
these subject matter and she's she when
we went back to the dormitory she told
her about you got to go see this cat so
I learned that the truth of what he was
saying cut through all of the other
stuff right you know all our rules about
language I mean she was hysterical so
that's when I I said Wow and actually
that's when I really thought well maybe
I can be a comedian because I had never
seen you had done it yes no I hadn't
done it all this that was 1969 or 70
okay I had met him before a crazy
[ __ ] I had uh I was in college
this is an interesting story I was in
college and he had a he was doing a
little movie down on at this house he'd
rented a house and this friend of mine
the results were funny said hey Richard
Pryor is doing a movie I mean it aren't
you want to come now see if you can get
in it and I said are you okay cool okay
so I walked down and they it was in this
house and I walk into the kitchen to
medium and his then-wife was there right
and she was crying I mean I she was
cooking pork chops that's what I
remember cuz funny how you remember
little details like yeah he was cooking
put he smelled pretty good too and she
was cooking pork chops and she was
crying and I wish she was standing there
the room with a hat and a blue peak she
is Sam I love you Richard I love you
kept saying I didn't know it [ __ ] I'd
know it that's all he sought to him
that's right that's what are you saying
I know it [ __ ]
so then he came over to me he said he
said pull out this little foil and he
said things go better with coke and I
you know I turned that down I said I
don't do that so then I got this little
parting with you a blatant turn down
over the smoke grass would you like oh
nice more grass and the grass you see
more light you see more better gonna
have that the line in the sand
yeah coke I saw what you would get to
some of my friends it was like
everywhere in show miss all the band's
had it although you know you staunch the
grass what cuz he says he said grass is
a wee grass so Holly all the bands had
it so it was around me all the time but
I just saw that you know I was never
self-destructive and I had tried to
learn from seeing performers who were
self-destructive and I saw people that
who were on coke a lot start to get
agitated over time and all I really
wanted to smoke war was just to calm me
down because I was a anxious person in
those days very neurotic and stuff like
that so I just said nah that's cool so
he gave me a little part in the movie it
was a sorry I don't know what it was
like a white man was on trial for all
the crimes of against black people that
I was and he was I was like washing him
he's a Richard Pryor deep cut yeah it
was it the jury there's a jury of blacks
there and watching this guy living I
worked 17 hours for $2 an hour and he
gave me a check for $34 from Richard
Pryor yeah yeah he handed to any
[ __ ] bounced really yeah so I
can bounce and I never saw him again for
like maybe 20 years or you know eight
ten years you know I by that time I was
a comedian I never I never mentioned it
because he was so crazy but I mean I
thought
I'm stable yeah yeah I used to call it a
nitroglycerin yeah cuz it was like you
didn't know what you know what you were
gonna get on a daily basis did it make
it difficult to be around him are you
just for me yeah because I've never been
around I mean look I I worked with him
on car wash I worked with him in
stir-crazy I worked I hope and I didn't
open it but I came up before him at the
comedy store
I got maybe that my best compliment ever
and my whole career from him with
because it was two nights he was blue
this is when he was really hot and they
put me on right before him at the comedy
store they were selling out cuz
everybody who's gonna be there he was
doing a whole week that's where you
recreated the mud Bowen character I saw
him do that from day one he came out
with one line and by the end of the week
he had the whole routine
I was quite interesting and so I thought
well I got to really be good I get to
night I had my album out I had some good
material I don't smoke dope so I said I
got some good stuff to myself I was I'll
see what I can do so I went out up ahead
of him and I gave her I did a really
good 20 minute [ __ ] set really
hilarious said and I thought well that's
pretty [ __ ] good and then he came up
what was in she came up on stage and he
beat me and you know I thought that it
was competitive but you know you know
that feeling of wow I said oh wow he
came right did this really better set
yeah so I thought okay objectively
better set yes we had this vibes we're
know he's pissed yeah yeah at his peak
yeah in those days as a performer right
he was playing a home game I mean just
gonna see him but he was up yeah I mean
I got tremendous laughs Langston so the
next night so you would have you were
like you were tough follow I was weird
but that's what happened next night I
was even better I really said well I got
only one more night and I really pulled
out all the stops right and I really
taught a [ __ ] audience apart I did my
Disneyland high routine which was my
little classic at that time and Annie
and and I got in a finish and he walked
up on stage he looked at me like this
name walked over us they said that
[ __ ] getting too funny that's just wow
all right and then he beat me again yeah
yeah because and I was sitting standing
in the back watching and I saw he's got
an extra gear is that little extra gear
right now you know just sitting there
watching him and I when he's got an
extra and his gear was he was a better
physical performer then I was like it's
the way he move and use his body I
didn't use my body that way and I said I
got to start to try to add that stuff
but he also you know I did that mudbone
routine he had that did he just was at
his peak in terms of his brilliance and
the type of material but I was very
close and then he came and he came and
he actually came and saw me record one
of my albums he actually came but George
Carlin came and Pryor came so I was kind
of in that groove those are my guys and
but he can at that time he was really by
the time my career ended I actually felt
I was better than him by the end because
I had a I had more Richard couldn't talk
about anything but the street because he
wasn't readin read he didn't have
education so and then after the fire he
was never - he was never the same to me
his material wasn't as strong you know
he had a lot of goodwill from the
audience I used to listen that sounds
like the cynic ami I closed my eyes yeah
you know if I really want to see if
somebody's saying funny stuff to me or I
close my eyes and listen and then I can
really judge it more objectively you
know because it's this really sharp is
this relief so I would listen to him and
I'd say oh he's not what he used to be
but the audience loved him more because
he talked through the fire and you know
and they would had great sympathy for
him but I could tell he's not what he
was you know and he wasn't really
reading and developing a wider he was
kind of staying in his Lane standing
right in that Lane and once he once he
wasn't living crazy anymore he didn't
have much to talk about what does that
think what what a fear of a lot of
comics that do party and get super wild
it's like when I get sober what am I
gonna talk about what kind of what will
I have you know yeah and I think I think
you know you can do it look like you
know I don't know look I I was neurotic
and a lot of people once I got
kind of clear and moving here did that
or see who knows what at that well what
happened it was a I was really at the I
was struggling in 1985 I had a I was
having a bit of a tough with Robin
Williams and high intensity comedy I was
having and I had a slow style and I was
starting to get TV people said can you
speed up can you speed up yeah we needed
a certain amount of laughs purrs and I
ran in it you know yeah they were in cuz
Robin was influential everybody you know
it's like everybody who's ever aside
influences the scene right and Robin was
for native Robin just killing places
destroying screen 8c but I would think
that you would be perfect for Booker's
as the and not antithesis messed up the
red with the perfect balance the yin and
the yang to high-energy comedy is like
almost like we're Steven right
we're like that calm place where he fell
into you know it's just like everybody
yes Steven Steven could Steven couldn't
find honey I worked I did a gig with
Steven we did some colleges and you know
how he's you just for 30 minutes you can
hang with Steven after 30 minutes you
can get a little boring for people
okay so I to come on before him but by
the third gig they said look we got to
have Steven come on before you cuz he
can't really he was too low-key for he
couldn't really follow me but I just was
having problems and then I had a really
terrible love breakup you know that was
really had me spun out and this guy
I was actually came off the road at the
time because I am i couldn't really
perform his games like I couldn't
perform well depressed like some people
I did a only time I ever got drunk on
stage I got drunk in Detroit just cuz I
was so depressed so I thought I'd I
drink these three a Long Island iced
teas before I went on stage he's really
what it was and I was just a disaster
and I remember when I came out through
it I told my agent you know get me off
the [ __ ] Road
I I got a I can't do this like this
and I remember Jerry Seinfeld I was
talking to him walking down Santa Monica
Jerry can [ __ ] work through anything
and they stay he's got a heavy schedule
coming up 2017 yeah I plan a beacon
theater every month nothing bothers him
nothing [ __ ] bothers him it's amazing
so I remember I said I think I'm coming
off the road cuz I'm depressed and he
said no no no no you got to press the
organism that's what he said no don't do
that
stay out there work through it press the
organism I said you know I've saved up
some money so I'm gonna do that until I
get better so then I got this call from
my agent he said I got a gig in
Australia they want to bring some
American comedians over for two months
they brought some from New York that
worked out well then I bring some from
LA three comedians would you like to do
it I can't get any comedians to take the
gig because they got to go away for two
months they don't want to leave the
states for two months they're gonna
affect their career and I went yes I
went to see y'all straight because I was
into tennis yeah I was a real I still
have a good tennis player and I'm when i
went to see Laver and where they came
from because I stray used to dominate
tennis in those days like and I said
well if I if too much ruins my career
and I don't have a career that's what
and so I said I'll take the gig yeah and
it changed my life that was in Sydney
for two months he was all Sydney Oh
Sydney for to love what yeah that's not
what I expected it uh yeah and I think
was if it had been a week yeah or a
bunch of I wouldn't be living here now
right because it was a two-month gig six
nights a week and what what is this gig
genuinely is that a club called Kinsella
is an interesting Club in the gay
section of town because I didn't know
Sydney was the second biggest place in
the world for gay people next to San
Francisco that's the that's the number
one place they have a gay Mardi Gras
here that's on TV every year and so I
didn't know that at the time so his club
cancellous was in the gay section of
town the Paddington area and I was only
being another I was
one of three straight people in the club
they had about 27 people working here do
you remember who you work with but he so
work with Steve Bluestein and Bill Kirk
and Bauer
okay okay and Bill didn't like Australia
didn't like the people you know they
called his bluff because he was very
temperamental and you know he could run
his bluff on club owners in America and
will be here they don't have a lot of
time for temperamental people they just
don't have any patience for it so bill
ran this thing we used to do 30 minutes
each the three of us each night right
and we alternated you open this this
week I love I'll do middle I'll do
whatever we just alternate each week
because we hadn't really ER so long
anyway bill God and I was I walked up I
feel like this ends with you closing all
the shelves but I want to hear no no
it's so the thing was bill back to a
dispute with the aussies thought from
the audience and during the show yeah I
didn't know until I got there because
there was this big brouhaha where you
can feel it when you walk up manager
without talking to these people trying
to keep them from kicking his ass huh
and I turned it turned out that he had
insulted some women from the stage and
even though I was he's a very
chauvinistic the men weren't going for
that yeah and they were gonna kick his
ass they were furious
so we calmed him down me and Steve did
art next and it was cool but the next
day the owner called us in three of us
and said you know look I'm not happy
with this he said Franklin you and Steve
were fine but what's happening bill
tried to say well I'll [ __ ] this I don't
like that and if you don't do this I'm
going home and I don't forget this
because you don't see this in the
state's to cats and he said well you
know bill we never had this problem till
you came here so you can go home or
finish to the rest of the month with he
just said this is calm right so we've
never had this problem till you came
here he called bills Bluff and Bill
hated that more you know he hated dad
more cuz he want to leave that money on
the table so he stayed you know oh yeah
yeah I mean even to think you know Bill
was a little and I wasn't there
obviously but it's easy he didn't have a
strong negotiating
headlining show bill wasn't a superstar
draw because he was able to come to
Australia for just two months also
there's two other comedians on a bill
like you guys do ten minutes more and
I'm bill and you can't split bills money
and we save on housing live live live
you're riding in the lift and you feel
like Will Smith and we dip and I get us
[ __ ] spliff yo live you know what it
is you understand it you get it it's
live they used to have the goofy ass
pink mustache they used to have the cart
the penny would have the pink mustache
on the outside of the car
didn't they on the outside of the car
and the [ __ ] pull up with us and
he would put it on the the hood of the
car
and then your you'll get out you'll get
out and get in the car and then he'd get
out and pull the moustache back in well
they've gone beyond that goofy ass [ __ ]
and they've grown up they're more subtle
so ya lift you know what it is order a
goddamn car it comes you drunk you go to
the car you didn't drive you don't own a
car you don't feel like riding your
stupid bike you order a lift you get the
concept you understand it if you're
really broke you can use lift line if
you want to ride with some strangers and
listen to what the [ __ ] they're talking
about sure do it I don't recommend it
but hey everybody's doing differently
anyways right now lift is our friend our
listeners a special deal get three free
rides up to $10 seats that's up to a $30
value with you enter the promo code
handsome Rambler just download the free
lifts out today and in a promo code
handsome Rambler in the payment section
you start with three free rides of the
technologies as up to a $30 value
that's promo code handsome Rambler
handsome Rambler live live
getting to live like Will Smith life is
a gift Toki know if you like snacks your
[ __ ] and a weirdo what type of weird
out on like snacks
everybody likes snacks so I'm not even
talking to anybody right now
Nate's box got great snacks so step your
snack game up
stop being a weirdo don't live life in a
mediocre way no matter what your income
is snacks is where you can truly live it
up no matter what just station in life
so stop being a [ __ ] step your snack
game up go to naturebox.com/tyler
favorites are almonds and some other
[ __ ] nature box they got all types of
snacks they switching up the snacks all
the time they really care about this
[ __ ] they care about snacks more than
you will ever care about snacks you
[ __ ] right now you could say either one
makes a box softer it has some Rambla
fans 50% off your first order
when you go to nature box complex
formula that's nature box cops last Ram
booth for 50% off your first order
naturebox.com/tyler
[Music]
get some smashed
[Music]
but the thing that made me really change
cuz I was very depressive when I first
came here you know I was it got me away
so I could kind of reflect on the things
that were bothering me you know yeah you
know I was away from friends I was away
from the influences of this country you
know there's a lot of things that you're
when you're brought up that you know I
had to think about what is success what
do I want even your friends can give you
bad advice though it's well intentioned
but Stanley what you need and I remember
I was 36 at the time and I was very sad
and I said well I'm not really feeling
good about my life and like if my next
36 years were like this I can't I'm
gonna see myself making it I'm too
depressed and I remember thinking so I'm
I'm gonna figure out while I'm here why
I am so depressed and that was what I
really needed I was focused on that
because I was I was one of those people
you know one of those comedians was
going through his head of therapists and
all that and that doesn't work for me
I'd go over and once even you had tried
therapy one time and I went no I don't
need to be I can't this is not gonna do
it for me I gotta figure out this on my
own
I feel like therapist be snitching is
she I'm not telling names but this one
guy him with the drinking right Oh
patient number eight so you what did you
I just started thinking I mean I would I
was meeting a lot of women too which was
kind of interesting because there were
no straight men very few straight men
sitting up and know how many black men
were there I mean at that time I guess a
guy actually was coming through the club
tonight who's coming with me who was
there yeah he was an American and he
recognized me you said he was you lived
in Sydney at the time all right
at the time I didn't know that there
were no straight men and also there were
the Aussie men are not gentlemen so the
women really don't like don't really
have a lot of good things to say about
Australian men and I didn't so I was a
gentleman that's still hold know that
yeah still to a certain degree still to
a certain degree but you you know you'd
find women that didn't have anything
good to say about Australian men cuz all
straight men ignore Oh
and don't pay it the attention to him
because I would I would meet women and
said are you a really a lovely woman and
she said thank you I said you must hear
that a lot
you would think cuz he yeah I said I
never heared well I never I when I say
really so I was a gentleman I was an
American I was I had an accent which I
didn't know yeah dreadlocks back then no
I had short hair I had a half row about
like this yeah nice and neat I was a
really good shape
and killing it yeah the women just
needed a tent and I told them all I said
look I just got broke up with this chick
I'm really so I'm I'm letting you know
I'm just gonna go out with whoever I can
go out with and they all said that's
fine as long as when I when we go out
you pay attention to me and I went yeah
that's okay and so that was an
interesting thing which was really easy
because there was no cell phones did I
just get confused trying to keep all
their details in it cuz I would focus on
them but you know they were they were
they actually helped me
they have good women they're very fair
which is Unilever and they play no games
absolutely zero games and so if you come
from LA which is really I used to be
confused because I would be meeting a
lot of chicks in LA cuz I was a
celebrity but in a way that didn't give
me the confidence you would think it
would because I started thinking it's
not really me it's it's how much
celebrity so good so when I came here
and nobody knew who I was I was actually
able to get a more objective view of
what I had to offer a woman right you
know which was they liked my
conversation it like it's also a good
place for a smart man if you're smart
here you can really they like that the
women are it's a very mental country
they like a smart person it's almost
like it's almost sexy to him they have a
term for that that I hate what's that
they say is sapiosexual sapiosexual
really you'll see on their dating
profile to say I'm a sapiosexual does
that mean they'd like smart people oh
wow that's weird I think it's what are
that sapien which is human oh yeah I
think is weak there's a winner but well
I don't I didn't run it to too many over
to especially
lay maybe in New York it would have been
better if you have no near it's got a
higher quality did you ever try New York
not to live to live on it you know no I
was you know the industry was out in LA
and so anyway I just I used to stay up
very late thinking and then I came to
this realization I stayed actually and
also the Aussies were really happy
people which I'd never lived in a
country without guns I didn't live in a
country that they don't chase Fame over
here in success it's not a folks here I
never lived anywhere where that I was
brought up on the American you got to
chase the fame it's and I had a element
of this is why I was confused I had an
element of notoriety and I wasn't happy
so that's when I really realized Galatia
think well if I get better known get a
little bit more money in my pocket I'll
be happier when that happened and I
wasn't that's when I had to really work
things out you know and I stayed for
three months and I remember one day I
just said to myself okay I'm ready to go
back and what my resolved was I'm gonna
plant my feet I remember I can be
murdered to myself I said I'm gonna
plant my feet I'm gonna figure out where
I stand on everything just where I stand
out where other people stand out where
my friends stand or where I stand on
every issue and not gonna be influenced
or buffeted by the opinions of others
anymore
and I'll take that I'll accept the
consequence as I said this to myself and
I did accept the consequences but I from
then on I was like man what were the
consequences well you know I wouldn't
compromise you know I just refused to
compromise and if it meant I wouldn't
get a gig or something like that I'd say
I don't want to compromise my style is
valid and you know there was a lot of
pressure on me to speed up to do stuff
and I said god dammit this is it you
know it's valid if I wasn't getting
laughs I'd be listening to you but as
long as I'm getting laughs the way I
want that's where I'm gonna do it
period and also it's not comedians
telling you this it's it was you know
like it is yeah you know and stuff and I
just went Alex I am NOT gonna do it I
mean some people might think that's and
then I came over here I started working
over here more because I felt well I got
a place I can work because my attitude
was I don't have to be a success in
America
I want to go I tell people this I went
to go where I'm treated best I want to
go over people on my wavelength I
realized I didn't feel I was on the
american wavelength but i felt i was on
the australian wait wait
they're very low-key they're very smart
they like witty dick aziz are very good
they're comedy on TV is terrible about
the people there we know just all the
people that people are pretty if they're
any idea yeah yeah they and that's
surprised because I'd be talking to
everything I haven't laughed like this
except in the states when I'm talking to
a comedian yeah well yeah yeah people
just cracked their witty bit dried a
layman a sarcastic
yes [ __ ] what just exist will any like
they like you because your since you and
my dry day so he's got a dry sense of
humor they like that now they they like
all kinds you can do stick you can do
bizarre stuff you can be very cerebral
they like it all like the comedy
festival a about everything here yeah so
that was so I said well okay you know uh
I've got some place where people you
know let me be me and if Americans won't
let me be me and and then I got tired of
the the racial dynamics of America the
black/white racial dynamics I can't
handle that anymore you know I don't
have it to deal with any of that here
and I saw that and my brother moved came
over to visit me and he even noticed
didn't so he moved here and he lives in
Canberra really he Hammond never left
now I never left MIT I yeah he's got all
that
Hannibal's already kind of doing it you
know you get it wasn't that flight so
long you got me saying that 21 years
along my family here so okay so that
two-month gig right yeah which turned
him did I extended it for a month myself
when the gig into that too I remember
telling Bluestein who was you know very
neurotic and he was and he would always
be telling me about how his mother had
done this and that cuz he was Jewish you
know our Jewish cat seemed to have
there's a lot of issues with their mom
you know and I remember I was walking up
to the club lady one night and ice
you know damn Steve you know cuz I was I
was seeing how happy these people were
and I wasn't used to that and I said you
know you you uh you gonna talk about
your mother for the rest of your life
you know you know why you're [ __ ] up
now so you got to change it's not like
you don't know why and once you know why
you got to change
I got simply for people don't know why
but you know why so it's on you now to
change you know and I said these people
can teach us a lot about how to be happy
and I'm gonna stay for an extra month on
my own dime to try to learn their secret
of how to deal with life and their thing
is that they don't complain they don't
complain about anything and that was
something I had not been used to because
in America you're encouraged to complain
you know and TV says what's your pet
peeve you know you see how people on
your shows what really what it pisses
you off but gets in rants you know
people around so there's a complaining
thing to the American culture that's
here in fact if you complain here people
will shun you they come on they'll say
it's funny I learned that I could call
it win gee you can hear it in Britain
England too if you're witty they hate
that British goes to British or winters
complainers right so and a lot of
British comedies based incomes yeah I
mean self-deprecation so if you sit down
you know if you say it like over here in
America you know you saw Windsor yeah I
got lots of [ __ ] so and they that's you
dad you know how do you shut you down
it's funny because it took they say I
like you going for a drink that's how I
made how's how's your life and you start
to give him a little sad story they
listen to it for about a minute I'm
gonna say she'll be right and that means
shut the [ __ ] up yeah she'll be right
mate
and that means let it go so you know and
I thought well that's great that's
[ __ ] great that's what I need because
we can indulge you know we can all
indulge over much in art you know
complaints right and I said and in
America they would you know kind of
encourage it you know tell me about it
you know life's not going to go oh
really you want to talk about it yeah
you're right now tell you they no listen
to that sad story for 20 minutes right
yeah an American bartender his role is
today tell me
therapist yeah so here so I said okay
okay all right I need that I need to
know how to do that and then I became a
person who just was able to roll with
life a lot better yeah the punches you
know ups and downs and when I went back
buddy Maura what years is again this is
85 85 I want to get a set at the improv
and Buddy Maura who used to manage Robin
and all of those cats he was in the
audience and he came up to me afterwards
he I know him and he said Franklin you
know you he didn't know I've been in
Austria you know Franklin I just saw
your set and yes there's really
something different about you and I went
ah buddy what the [ __ ] you're talking
about it's the same material Ivan do it
he said no no no no it's not there's
something different about you Wow he
picked up on me but something in me a
calmness I guess so you know once I said
so might you know once I kind of got my
feet I just became this kind of a lone
wolf kind of guy you know even moving
over here all my friends thought I was
crazy cuz that's when you really ghost
85 yeah yeah ain't no checking in seven
dollars a minute the car you gone for
real but I didn't even hear Oh 97 okay
oh yeah I but I would come over in
vacation yeah because I wanted to you
know see those girlfriends it's you
actually only I did pretty well here but
Sydney I never did as well as in Sydney
because here is a morgue there's more
heterosexuals but in Sydney I just you
know that was actually Plus think the
women were so easy to get along with
that and I'd had two chicks in the
States but who are really high
maintenance you know and so I realized
you didn't have to the chicks were smart
Nasik plus the culture here is women pay
their way yeah okay I know it's not my
first trip they pay their way and if you
try to pay for them that's when they get
mad or do they get a little bit that
delays you know don't do that yeah I've
tried happen to me it's got I'll go
ahead yeah I tried to buy my first trip
out here in in Melbourne in 2011 I was
out with this girl then I tried to buy
her a drink and she was like no I'll
keep my own drink and I said oh this
night is over okay but then everything
went well and we know you can buy the
drink but they'll say well the next
one's on me
it's an amazing thing and that kind of
right away that takes a little pressure
off you because you know you
I remember thinking about well you know
what they're invested in the evening
like it's not like I got to show them a
good time it's like we got to show each
other a good time also they're there
they're straight ahead like if they
don't feel anything they won't even you
won't they won't go out which is the
second time because they don't feel it
and did I and that's kind of interesting
for you first it's a jolt when you call
them up you think things went well and I
said nah but they don't want to waste
their money I could understand that they
don't want to put any more money into
some they don't really see you you have
in the future so you really kind of get
a if they're out with you the second
time you kind of know they really like
you right whereas the American girl be
like hey is another free dinner aren't
you you know go go out you hungry - so
y'all do that Oh American chicks say
yeah if I want a good dinner or good go
to a good concert I do that and then
then they break the cat's heart when
they say I don't think of you that way
you know do you know but over here it's
after the band says thank you good night
they don't feel that way so that was the
very I said okay I have been able to go
out with an American chick sense to be
honest I haven't I can't put up I tried
but when I try to explain to them hey
let's kind of go you know we they don't
they don't want to hear that let's go
Dutch and they think you're just a cheap
[ __ ] you know what I mean and I
just actually ruled him out I just just
want to deal with him cause he girls but
at my age I'm having a tough time at 67
it's a [ __ ] that's a whole
nother game what's the single scene like
a 67 it's pathetic
what it's supposed to be that's if you
know that's if you want to go out with
women with figures because older women
you know 50 in above which is like I
till I was 52 I could still catch women
in their 20s yeah here I could still 27
28 this son what happen you felt I went
through the twilight zone did that wall
where you walk you know I can't used to
say me when you steal steal like plus
you know the chicks either young chicks
they're so smart it's not like going out
with a young chick right yeah
cats would say why you still hit on
these young chicks you know and I said
well because I could still catch on
number one yeah I mean I told the guy I
said you know one day and I use 20 I
said you know one day I said I can still
catch him I'm like my dreadlocks were
dark you know I was still pretty trim
are still pretty trim and I could still
catch them meet him on the street
charming go out with him strip moving
like that's a tough like walking past
that's a tough streets tramps that's how
I used to meet up cuz I wouldn't go meet
him at clubs I you know they're friendly
women cuz there's not a lot of predator
[ __ ] here you know so they're not scared
of men strangers you know
American accent also disarmed similar
you say hey how are you they hear an
accent and so you know it's like an
Austrian guy in America
same thing you know hey girl you know
got Chico here at Aussie accent so they
are a little bit more open and if you're
polite which I am they'll listen and so
but then when you get right at 52 I had
this chick 27 and then I had a chick 35
and then all of a sudden the same
approach you know I was just it just
wasn't working you just you know it was
like I told this cat before I said well
there's gonna come a time when no matter
what I do I'm not gonna be able to catch
a young girl a younger woman you know
so why should I retire before that
happens why should I quit push it to the
level yeah because it's gonna happen
right is gonna [ __ ] happen any did 52
was like I told Pat I said it's like I
was in a Twilight Zone episode I'm with
these chicks
I'm sitting there's this invisible wall
I walked through I looked back and the
chicks are on that one and I can't get
it back I can't get back to him so then
it becomes alright I got my friend
tonight he's the Houston okay he's uh he
used to be a real ladies man he's he's
still ladies 55 right he's still good
good-looking cat but same thing though
the younger women and he still likes no
you like the woman with a shape or
figure right and women 50 and above a
lot of them don't take care of himself
they've had kids you know and they've
got they've let themselves go women's
60s you know so my age I'm 67 I I can't
you can't see me with a 67 year old
chick people do that but I mean look
when I look at him cuz I give him a look
you know I mean I'm walking down the
street and I'm saying if I could see an
older woman that's you know catches my
attention but so dimmest like okay then
I I try my approach on the younger one
which is was pretty charming like but I
noticed I couldn't get him to go have
coffee with me
like I don't need to chicks down there
at the Devil Went the little French
chick at the desk yeah she's a cutie
part and Celine is her name another one
out front so Danny and I both home got
boyfriends but you know the one with the
striker
yeah okay good Intel she's from
Manchester England right okay and we're
doing a very good job - there's a
[ __ ] good job had him smiling
laughing yeah yeah you know and I don't
know if I didn't they both have
boyfriends you know and you know but I I
don't know if I but I
but what I found is I couldn't close the
deal anymore that was the problem at my
age because now when I walk up to a
chick they see an old guy that's the
thing no matter you may feel young but
when they turn they see they see a guy
that they're not really outside of their
age range
you nearly need a really broad thinking
woman to think oh I'll go out with the
sordid cat but most of them you know
friend of mine another cat said the same
things today ages - he used to have a
lot of good yo he said age is the
greatest obstacle man it can't be beat
and you know I've he was right I should
have come here about five years earlier
later America close to 2013 I should
have come about 2010 mm-hmm that's okay
but when I got all over here I get I
think you know what I knew that she does
change I've met this chick I'm walking
down Swanson and I see this drop-dead
[ __ ] gorgeous Chyna you know asian
chick with just legs legs are my thing
I gotta have the legs some cats need ass
but I got the leg I need the legs [ __ ]
the ass I need the lake she had and I so
she walking she went to this little shop
right over here on Swanston Street and I
got it
and I followed her in and I saw I just
walked you know my thing was always be
buried directly so I just walked in just
to tell you I think you really won the
most beautiful women I've ever seen and
she blushed and smile thank you very
much and I said you know and I started
to walk away and then I thought you know
if I want to take a chance yeah and I
said listen you know would you like to
have a coffee right now and she said
well you know I normally don't do this
but yeah all right [ __ ] you still got
this [ __ ] man you did I thought to
myself we walked over right across the
street we're sitting up for about 15 20
minutes of [ __ ] is just sparkly you know
it's just
[ __ ] sparkling immediate coffee day
Coffee day and she's engaged we're
having a beautiful and then all of a
sudden out the [ __ ] blue she says how
old are you and I went oh [ __ ] to myself
like I said I told her to chew that
detect I was 65 she was gone in about
two minutes man my only regret telling
the truth I've never lied but you know
that was if you were gonna do it that
was a couple of times all right
you know and then get to that cuz like
when my girl my daddy seven-year-old
girl I was 52 it I didn't tell her till
the third time but we were he did also
that I thought I need to tell her how
old I am cuz I know I don't look my age
and I sat her down at this little place
and I said how old I am
I'm just picturing you before you meet
up with her like pace and Franklin you
gotta do this alright she's thinking
about to tell you got her Beezus oh I'm
52 I said I'm you know I gotta tell you
how old I am and she said okay I said
all I need you to look 52 and I was T
just got up and came around and sat on
my lip said it's okay it's alright but
I've been out with her a couple of times
right we'd had a great time yeah you
know and I was told but when I said 65
man it was like the walls that same
invisible wall was gone in two minutes
and I went oh man this is gonna be
harder than I thought
mmm you know my friend used to lie he
used to like that lace until they could
check his age on the internet they
busted him a couple times yeah you know
on the Internet
but I went now what am I gonna do and
that and 67 it's like you know you're a
now you know whole nother zone I got
this chick coming tonight
who's 49 right yeah that's not bad who's
the I you know
yeah I mean I realized that that's
really that's about that's that's where
I got a fish now if that even a that's a
big gap for ya for some of them you know
it's hard man I ain't lyin it's hard you
know I look at these young boys they
don't deserve these young women they
don't [ __ ] deserve I mean I don't
know how the [ __ ] to do with these I see
these square-ass [ __ ] with
these chicks man hey man you know how
you get the young ones again yeah start
back doing stand-up I watch to see so I
watch the sea salt with about 25 sees
soaps heat hope see so s ee s oh the new
ad free no ads this you won't hear this
I'll see so see so we'll advertise on
other plant but they don't have and
state believe in the power of
advertising but they don't want to
burden your eyes with that it's crazy
advertising is the only thing that you
can you can you can advertise advertise
hey you wanna advertise right here is
you want this [ __ ] you want your face
on this bench and then you put your face
on the bench and now it's advertising
you instead of advertising the fact that
you could use that for see so every
episode of SNL SNL so you can look up
that weird as Michael Jordan sketch from
years ago it's a great man is a great
CISOs ad-free three ninety-nine a month
three ninety-nine a month that's 48
dollars a year or that's forty seven
dollars and eighty-eight cents a year if
one of you math nerds want to be a [ __ ]
see so right now my listeners contract
see so free for two months two months 60
days 58 or 59 if one of your months so
you can't get anywhere else
original series take my wife Harmon
quest that's just go to see SOCOM s EES
Oh calm right now to sign up two months
free promo code rambling see SOCOM promo
code you haven't been on stage since
2013 2013 Wow let it I let it yeah I
just kind of went I've said you know I
just feel like I've said everything I
wanted to say there's no and that was
another thing you know I I didn't want
to be looking for new material anymore
you know it's kind of like like my
friend my girlfriend she says all right
you know you're still funny because I'm
still pretty funny when you chat and
stuff yeah yeah hilarious right now yeah
she said I said you know there's no easy
way to be good because you saw used to
just there's no easy way to be good I
mean I can't people don't know that I
mean I'd have to start I'd be have to be
serious about getting my material
because I don't do old stuff so I'd have
to be really focusing on what's going on
I don't really want to work nights
anymore yeah you know it's for me
you know I never was a night guy like a
lot of performers I'm a day guy I'm up
at 6:00 every morning so I just I said
there's no easy way to be good it was
I'd have to be serious about it because
I can't just walk up there and [ __ ]
people yeah so but I don't miss it like
you know all my friends miss it but you
know I have even I don't miss it you
know I I get as much of a kick making my
friends laughs talking to us is is going
onstage you know myself
yeah did okay so it's been three years
and was those last few years 2010 to
2013 were you doing it a lot I did it
was doing I was trying to get back on TV
so I go down to the economy and magic
club where you could they would DVD they
tape you you know and you could and I
sent it you know I sent it to all of the
shows I had a this really funny five
minute you can actually see some of it
on YouTube actually so in my comedy and
magic and I said okay let me put
together a really sharp because I knew
my age for example this guy who used to
book Letterman he came out I know Eddie
Eddie bro
Eddie Brill so he came out to the Uptown
show which was right and he you said I'm
scouting for Letterman so I went down
and I did this really funny set and he
had all these young comics and he came
and he said man you still got it man
your stuff is still really really sharp
man I'm gonna I'll be getting I'll be
getting in touch with you when I go back
and then like it I got about a month
later they caught he said I ran your
name by Dave and Dave said he's too old
period wow that was it Dave said nah
[ __ ] are you old yeah so you know part
of me said okay so you know I tried to
get on Craig Ferguson I tried to get on
Leno and I found that I couldn't get on
Elaine Boosler had warned me because she
couldn't get on TV anymore she I was
here and I asked her what's the scene
like when I come back - she said well I
can't get on TV that's why she retired
she you know she said I can't promote my
gigs you know she's made a shitload of
money so you know she said I can't get
on any of the TV shows and I'm not
really up for the fight anymore and
that's really what I really found at
that age was I'm not up through the
fight yeah to get noticed anymore and if
this is where you know I I'm happy with
what I've done I have no regrets I don't
have any bitterness I did my best
my attitude is I did my best and I
finished up ahead of the game and okay
and cuz I had I don't want to live my
life I'm very committed to not living my
life angry or frustrated like some
people I know I know some people who
just
and you know and I just said I just want
to clear it all that out I want to you
know live and enjoy life so I I just
want to live I had a friend who told me
what he said I can get you college gigs
I can get you this before I left he was
trying to keep me there you know and I
said I just want to live now man like
yeah you know I'm not interested in I'm
not interested in trying to build my
profile anymore I don't need I don't
need the money you know so you saved
well and invested oh no I just
I'm just homeless when you're homeless
you don't need me I did I was always
well you know from day one mmm I was
very cognizant of the need to save my
money and invested because I'd seen the
cautionary tales oh yeah entertainers
that had ended up bankrupt and so I knew
I'm you know money for me was freedom I
never wanted a lot of acquisitions I
didn't need three cars I think I'll give
me a nice little house in a car I have a
nice little condo but I won't over here
in a really good section of town that is
expand when I bought it I didn't I just
bought it cuz I liked it but now that's
one of the hottest areas in the city you
can't even get in there and it's amazing
but I'm not thinking about moving but I
always saved with with the idea of I
don't want to have to do a gig because I
need the money
right you know I don't want to have to
do so I was save and I my acquisitions
were and I invested pretty well in real
estate and I invested in shares and so I
did it all yeah you know and and like I
say you know I don't I tell people there
are people a lot of more money than me
but they're not living any better than
me I can do whatever I want I could buy
it whatever I want but I just really buy
books and yeah DVDs by Handel nice you
know it's uh but my biggest obstacle is
trying you know if I had a good lady
that I was attracted to
my life would be pretty much perfect
that's really been the struggle you know
just cause age I'm still charming let me
try tinder no I'm not doing that I don't
know this [ __ ] this [ __ ] max a lot of
[ __ ] out the box yeah yeah it does in
the grey it just knocks a lot of [ __ ]
out the box man you'd be surprised how
many women like that man for real like a
Chinese chick didn't here's another one
about the with retired and stop and
stand up did you just feel the shift
over time in your thought process so
just how you cuz I'm always my brain is
just constantly just going about stuff
or that this thing that happened
yesterday or this person or how they
move their body and that all types of
stuff like that just and so did you do
you feel this is just you don't have the
desire to stand up and your mind is
still operate the same or do you feel
like more relaxed it's a lot more you
know the guy was a fairly once I the
bottom line was once I kind of had that
epiphany back in 85 which kind of put me
you know eliminated my neurotic slash
side in this and my insecurities and I
became a just a person that was fairly
confident without being arrogant about
just going through life you know and
kind of easy comfortable with myself you
know and I think the journey in life I
tell people is to find out who you are
you know in a way a lot of people never
find out who they really are and I
remember that I remember thinking to
myself I found out who I am I'm a
serious you know when I was a comedian I
was always wrestling with my serious
nature versus the demands of the
profession right and the fact that
people would always want me to be on
yeah okay I remember once in Seattle I
had to do it really early morning
show to promote my gig and I just was
sick of corner radio show yeah and I
went in and I wasn't in a mood to do any
jokes and the DJ said okay I mean what
Dukes do you want to do you know during
the Congressional not gonna do any joke
so he said hey this is Tom he said I
said I said just just talk to me
yeah he was [ __ ] and I was adamant and I
ain't give a [ __ ] that
so he did so he started asking me
questions and we had a really nice
conversation every night he and I might
say something a little witty but
basically serious and then at dinner you
know that's the best [ __ ] interview
he said I've ever done well anyway what
happened was and a sold-out gig that
week and people came up to me after the
show and I said how did you know I was
in town they said well we heard you on
that show and you were so interesting we
decided to see what type of sense of
humor you had we didn't yeah that's what
they said what you were just such an
interesting person we said let's go see
what kind of sense so I realized that
the audience is you know they you know
would they don't mind that right but
your program so that was always for me a
real battle of trying to stay to my
nature yeah and and also you know do
that and so once I kind of got out of it
and it's like I just went okay my mind
doesn't really I don't have what you're
talking about where I'm still looking
anymore you know for the next oddity or
you know which is what you're looking
for something that strikes you eye
strikes a little bit odd or you notice
so you think about it you know I'm not
doing that anymore you know it's really
inadvertent now if I'm I'm funny and so
I'm relaxed about that and I know I call
it the antenna you know if I were to get
back and I'd have to put the antenna
back up right you know reading the paper
I used to read the paper looking for you
know all kinds of stuff because I was
doing a lot of global material right
into my career I was no longer doing I
wasn't married you know a lot of my
friends you know they marry and so your
material goes from being single to being
married with kids that's
additional thinker and I never married
and so I started focusing not on
political stuff but actually global
events I wonder a few comedians really
do install out Russia and Zimbabwe and
and stuff and which was really that's
when I thought I was better than Richard
right because I went he can't you know
he could never broaden out like this and
I was making people cracked up about
tragic stuff you know then I would so I
had really but I had to because I
couldn't fall back on all my kids are
doing this or my wife is giving me grief
you know what I mean it's a lot of cats
it'd be weird if you just wrote those
jokes anyway just get somebody pregnant
just for the material yeah well she has
weird cravings oh the baby all this baby
sucking on those titties don't have to
be mighty I said well how am I gonna
stay and so I was really into you know
world affairs and they have a lot of
world news over here they show that they
won't you know I America shows focuses
on mostly but here they there's a
network SBS and they really it's all
global and I was I I'd see what was
going on a Zimbabwean Indonesia or
Malaysia you know things that Americans
wouldn't even know what was going on but
I even know that they exist yeah and I
enjoyed walking out on stage and talking
to the audience about something that I
that they didn't know about but I was
going to entertain them and educate him
at the same time in a funny way and I
really got a kick out of that because I
was bringing up stuff that a lot of
people didn't know about and that was
like a real challenge it's like you're
you're bringing up stuff and how do you
you've got a an ain't Joe going on the
journey you know with me and stuff like
that so you know but no man I I don't
miss it I thought about maybe writing a
series like my last gas I created a
series you know when I saw Louie yeah
and Curb Your Enthusiasm and so I
created this series like you know I play
clarinet too and I thought I'm gonna
create a thing where I'm a little
musician in LA you know I was gonna make
my characters gonna see 50 but he's
gotta be dating Sam yeah
gonna be gonna be a musician it's
hilarious I wrote three scripts
hilarious I couldn't sell that
[ __ ] man right I went to show
time I went HBO Larry David loved that
he actually sent a face a to HBO forming
he loved it Larry doesn't like a lot of
[ __ ] and he said you know he's grumpy
[ __ ] and he said uh you know let
me see your scripts I sent him two
scripts and you know yeah a couple weeks
later he's a great he's a great you know
he's sending his blue email great you
know something it's of nature yo for you
you know I said cool you know but they
didn't end in high FC yeah you know I
said I thought it would be perfect right
I did to him but the cat didn't they
said no we can't you won't get any
traction here and I went well that's it
shutting it down you know what I mean
that's it
I wouldn't you know because I felt I
could do something very provocative you
know I had one episode where he my
character ends up with this really young
chick who likes to be choked while she's
where you [ __ ] her and stuff like that
cuz that happened to me in real life I
had this gorgeous chick like choke
choked or just would be so yeah you
can't really yeah I mean she took a
double head she took my hands and I like
Undertaker choked she told me man this
is what I want you to do I said oh [ __ ]
I did for three months all right you
know
and I was always worried let's see what
shames our minds no she was and it made
a difference because she'd be super it'd
be me because she'd say it's gotta be
hard it's got to be really hard I'm
thinking and I wasn't into that but I'd
say well you know I'll try this and then
yeah she would really really turn her on
and you know I say well you know she'd
get really what worked up my everything
in myself yeah you better have a orgasm
cuz I'm facing 25 a life and yeah you
know you know and and I I just I
couldn't do it anymore and I you know I
said look how I'm sorry but you know I
can't be choking you anymore you know
it's just that something I can really do
you know
yeah and that's when that relationship
kind of went down
cuz she liked it and you know I tell
people you know you can't change the way
you're wired right you know I'm sure who
was ever with her now is choking her
every time every time see every time
just a strong choking Missa that's it I
gotta be like weekend's man like every
time I even like to PM post-lunch sexy
post-lunch
that's too much tried not if I tried to
get out of choking her I tried all kinds
of [ __ ] did but she'd move her head over
trying to choke me well
this is fun but hard to get choked well
in Hollywood you blew it that was here
that was a chick well sandy blew it in
that tank in those stories you look into
other men's hands you know oh man
yeah that was something but has
educational [ __ ]
because I thought you wanted it is it's
educational because I feel like every
woman I've been with in a way or every
event teaches you more about the reality
of life as it was to what you've been
taught like now here's a woman who was a
very intelligent woman smart you would
never know you don't think Oh cuz she's
a lawyer she don't like that [ __ ] hard
but she you don't like to get smart and
yelled at yeah so that taught me more
about the individuality of people yeah
because you know they don't have to be
crazy you know that the illusion is not
the illusion but the assumption is you
know only crazy people are into that
right but rough sex and stuff and that
is all right afterward you say okay I
know a little bit more about life now it
helps me be more open-minded hmm when I
deal with people because I know that you
know you just have to be prepared for
really all kinds of individuals and they
are here you know I'm not really into
judging people you know who aren't doing
dangerous things to other people right
so I always feel like each of those
things teach me more I would have never
you know I never dealt with a chick that
need to be choked I did sudden there's
one in your life to how you deal with it
yeah how do you really handle this do
you say I'm not into that but then you
say well you know would that make me
selfish if I don't choke her and stuff
right
Elfi ation be the bigger person you know
what I mean but my Rishta feeling weak
yeah but that was an interesting
experience you know absolutely anyway
but look how much longer get excited I
was like trying to figure out a way to
wrap it up and then you would say this
compelling story hello I'm Chris Gethard
and here with me as dream analysis
expert Gary Richardson and we are here
to give you a taste of a brand new
podcast called in your dreams presented
exclusively by the fine folks at Casper
we listen to the wildest weirdest dreams
emitted to us by you our listeners and
we do our best to figure out just what
those dreams could possibly mean side of
my song fed and there are cute Lewis and
the news you're saying this person might
have interests in style and fashion
specifically you can tell that from that
voicemail 99% certainty plus we'll be
joined by some very special guests the
word brutality comes to mind
mortality blood blood tality
subscribe to in your dreams right now on
iTunes or wherever you get your podcast
thanks for listening
good night
this has been an ear wolf production
executive produced by Scott Aukerman and
Chris Bannon for more information and
content visit Earwolf calm